[Musique]
on va parler de cinéma à présent
dimanche prochain se déroule la onzième
édition du festival régional du
court-métrage au Clayes-sous-Bois pour
en parler avec nous à distance Nawel Ben
Ahmed bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes médiatrice
culturelle à l'espace Philippe Noiret
aux Clayes-sous-Bois au total vous avez
sélectionné 11 courts métrages sur des
thèmes assez variés comment est-ce que
vous les choisissez ces festives ces
court-métrages
alors c'est court métrage cette année en
fait ils ont été choisis par un groupe
de spectateurs de l'espace noir et en
fait les abonnés à notre newsletter on a
fait un appel comme ça et donc sur le
volontariat plusieurs personnes ont vu
tous les films et on sélectionné selon
leur gouttes voilà de spectateurs
respectives et comme ça ils sont arrivés
à trouver 11 films on se court-métrage
qui leur vraiment qui les a tous réunis
et donc ils sont tous vraiment très
impatients de les montrer à tout le
monde et il y a une durée limitée par
exemple il faut pas qu'ils excède 15
minutes 20 minutes
alors en fait le but c'était d'avoir en
tout trois heures de film et de se
retrouver donc avec deux sessions d'une
heure 30 donc on a essayé de de pas
choisir les films forcément sans leur
durer donner leur chance à tous les
films mais c'est vrai que parfois par
contre des films ont dû être un petit
peu choisis ou éliminer si c'était trop
long trop court pour rentrer dans ces
trottes dans ces trois heures pardon et
donc on se retrouve avec on ce film
alors que les années précédentes c'était
plutôt 15 films au 16 film et donc au
niveau des thèmes c'est assez varié on
le disait à l'instant il y a vraiment
des courts métrages qui abordent des
thèmes sérieux et d'autres un petit peu
plus comique
oui oui il y a vraiment pour tous les
goûts cette année il y a de la comédie
de l'action de la science-fiction du
documentaire c'est vraiment comment dire
une série de courts métrages très
différents mais tous de d'une très
grande qualité et au niveau des
réalisateurs est-ce que ce sont souvent
les mêmes qui reviennent vous avez vous
avez aussi des débutants
non cette année la plupart sont des
débutants c'est la première fois qu'on
les accueille au festival il y a juste
un réalisateur qui a déjà fait festival
pardon une année précédente mais sinon
c'est tous des nouveaux réalisateurs et
en plus on a la chance cette année sur
11 films 10 films seront représentés
donc des réalisateurs seront là pour
parler de leur film et à répondre aux
questions donc c'est vraiment une grande
chance qu'on a cette année et alors quel
est l'objectif de ce festival c'est
mettre en avant des courts-métrages qui
ne seront pas forcément diffusés dans
les salles de cinéma
oui voilà tout à fait en fait l'objectif
c'est pour nos spectateurs de montrer la
forme du court-métrage qui finalement
n'est pas forcément toujours valorisé au
cinéma donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
pouvoir faire découvrir un autre
spectateurs une nouvelle forme de film
et aussi des nouveaux réalisateurs les
faire émerger et participer aussi à
développer leur carrière et ce qu'il y a
un court-métrage qui vous a marqué plus
qu'un autre vous
oui moi il y a un court-métrage qui est
libre interdit c'est un documentaire en
fait sur une librairie en Slovénie qui
accueille tous les livres interdits à
travers le monde tous les livres qui
sont censurés ils sont ressemblés pardon
dans cette librairie et c'est un
documentaire vraiment très très
intéressant et qui nous apprend beaucoup
de choses et alors cette année le
festival est sous la présidence de
l'acteur émetteur en scène Alexis
Michalik c'est un honneur pour vous une
fierté
oui c'est une très grande fierté en plus
avec cette année c'est l'artiste associé
de notre saison culturelle donc on a eu
l'occasion déjà de l'accueillir lors de
la présentation de saison on a aussi eu
sa pièce une histoire d'amour en janvier
donc là encore une fois avec le
court-métrage le festival ça il est le
président de notre jury et puis en soi
aussi à 21h on a la chance d'avoir son
film une histoire d'amour en
avant-première et il sera là il reste
après le festival pour présenter son
film et aussi lors du débat après le
film donc c'est à 21h là séance et donc
vous le disiez tout à l'heure il y a
deux sessions qui sont prévues une
première session pour diffuser les six
premiers courts métrages ensuite une
deuxième session pour pour le restant et
au milieu en fait il y a un temps
d'échange avec les réalisateurs
voilà tout à fait en fait à la fin de
chaque session on garde un petit temps
d'échange avec les réalisateurs ensuite
une pause qui permet quand même au
public de respirer parce qu'on se rend
compte que trois heures de visionnage ça
peut être intense donc après cette pause
on repart sur une deuxième session et
encore une fois après
l'interview de réalisateur sachant que
les réalisateurs seront là aussi pour
répondre informellement lors de de la
pause au bar etc pour échanger avec les
spectateurs et donc à la toute fin au
final de ces trois heures de visionnage
on vote pour le court-métrage favori du
jury de qui est les composés le jury
cette année
alors le jury qu'on visite de plusieurs
personnes de professionnels de la
culture donc à Lexi Michalik évidemment
qui est le président du jury il est
aussi composé Daida asgarder Zardet
pardon qui en fait est une méthode
ancienne et qui est comment dire à
l'origine de la pièce pour que personne
qu'on diffuse la veille et qui travaille
qui est dans le cercle aussi d'Alexis
Michalik ainsi que Régis vallée qui est
un comédien et puis aussi on nous avons
un placeur qui est de la culture des
Clayes-sous-Bois qui participent au jury
donc ça permet vraiment d'avoir
différents points de vue pour pour
choisir les trois films préférés du
juriste qui sera pas évident j'en suis
sûr et donc au total il y a six trophées
à gagner
deux trophées un du meilleur comédien
meilleur comédienne les trois prix du
jury et le prix du public puisque les
spectateurs peuvent voter pour leur
court-métrage favoris alors justement
comment ça va se passer concrètement
comment est-ce que les spectateurs vont
pouvoir voter
alors quand les spectateurs arrivent en
fait on leur donne le programme des
courts métrages à l'intérieur il y a un
petit bulletin de vote qu'ils vont
garder précieusement et à la fin de la
deuxième saison il y aura une urne dans
laquelle ils pourront déposer leurs
bulletin pour pour donner leur vote et
ce qu'il y a des critères qui font un
peu plus pencher la balance le jeu des
acteurs le scénario la musique
oui je après je pense que ça dépend de
chaque personne chaque personne va
vraiment voter selon son affinité pour
certains films il y a peut-être des
thématiques qui vont plaire comme je
vous ai dit le documentaire peut-être
que ça va plaire après il y a d'autres
personnes qui vont peut-être en effet
être par rapport aux jeux d'acte à
chaque fois c'est une surprise donc on
sait pas chacun vote avec son avec son
propre avis et bien merci beaucoup Nawel
benamen d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je le rappelle le festival régional du
court-métrage aux Clayes-sous-Bois se
déroulera le 12 mars à l'Espace Philippe
Noiret de Clayes-sous-Bois de 14h à 19h
l'entrée est ouverte à tous et allez
gratuite
[Musique]